Hey Leute, wir machen heute...du darfst es ruhig sagen!
- Schokobrötchen!
Schokobrötchen!
Irgendwie passt es zum Schulstart weil Schokobrötchen hatte ich immer in der Schule mit und ich erzähl euch noch was Witziges:  Meine Freundin und ich
- übrigens heute noch meine beste Freundin - haben in der Grundschule immer unsere Pausenbrote getauscht weil die hatte immer...was hatte sie immer?
Wurst?
- Sucuk?
Genau, so ne Truthahnwurst und ich hatte halt immer entweder Schokobrötchen oder was hatte ich...Philadelphia glaube ich.
Du hattest die gekauften gehabt, ne?
- Jaja klar, meine Mama hat die nicht morgens selber gemacht.
Aber die gekauften schmecken nicht.
Nee, also... ja was heißt "Die schmecken nicht"? Selbstgemacht schmeckt einfach viel, viel besser. Und Hamza hat euch verrückt gemacht auf Instagram
weil ich die gemacht habe und die sind  SO fluffig. Kennt ihr diese Gebäcke, die ihr
zusammenpresst und die einfach wieder aufgehen?
So sind die! Und jetzt will ich auch gar nicht lange drumherum schnattern. Ich hab hier meine Hand schon im Teig
also beziehungsweise im Mehl und ich gebe da direkt die Prise Salz dazu
und die Trockenhefe. Ihr könnt auch frische Hefe nehmen, da nehmt ihr einfach einen halben Würfel. Dann gebe ich schon mal Zucker mit dazu.
Also die Zutaten findet ihr in der Infobox.
- Die Zutaten findet ihr definitiv in der Infobox.
- Ich hab so Lust drauf! Und jetzt bilde ich hier eine Mulde, gebe da einmal die lauwarme Milch hinzu
und die geschmolzene Butter habe ich in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen und etwas abkühlen lassen
und jetzt mit den sauberen Patschehänden rein und einfach zu einem Teig verkneten.
Meine Lieben ich habe den Teig jetzt hier auf der Arbeitsfläche geknetet, ich brauche dafür überhaupt keine Küchenmaschine, weil das geht so schnell!
In zwei Minuten oder drei habt ihr schon so einen schönen Teig, schaut mal wie glatt die Oberfläche ist! Und jetzt müssen wir das Ganze
gehen lassen für
45 minuten zugedeckt.
Ich mache das so: es gibt bestimmte Hefeteige, da mache ich einfach die Schüssel voll mit oben drüber ein bisschen Mehl.
Der hier trocknet aber aus, wenn wir den nicht mit Öl oder mit Fett benetzen, daher nehme ich Backtrennspray.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch ganz normales Öl aus der Flasche nehmen, aber das kann man halt besser dosieren. Einfach rein legen, auf jeden Fall
auf die Oberfläche nochmal Backtrennspray und jetzt wie gesagt zugedeckt an einem warmen Ort gehen lassen und in 45 Minuten sehen wir uns wieder.
So, der Teig ist schön aufgegangen.
Mindestens doppelt so dick ist er jetzt und jetzt nehmen wir ihn raus aus der Schüssel und das geht auch super einfach.
Und jetzt kommt der
meiner Meinung nach beste Teil, jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere Schokotröpfchen, die sind backfest und die gebe ich hier einfach über den Teig und
dann zügig einkneten, weil wir haben ja Handwärme.
- Echt so viele?
Also ich übertreibe immer gern ein bisschen.
Schon zügig jetzt einarbeiten weil wir haben ja Handwärme und wir wollen ja nicht, dass die Schokolade schmilzt.
Nachdem ich das einige Sekunden ganz kurz eingearbeitet habe, nehm ich mir meine Teigkarte und stech mir hier aus dem großen Teigklumpen
zehn kleine Teigrohlinge aus und diese Teigrohlinge dann ganz einfach zu Kugeln formen.
Und jetzt (Räuspern)
tun wir das...
Woooow!
- Ja, woow!
Was ist das denn für ein Backblech mit ausziehbaren Bügeln?
Und total...hochqualitativ!
Ja und ein bisschen dreckig unten, aber ist nicht schlimm!
- Äh, das zeigt nur, dass wir das oft und gerne benutzen! (lacht)
Okay, die Rede ist von meinem
Backblech aber in diesem Video will ich euch darüber nicht so viel erzählen, da kommt ein extra Video. Auf jeden Fall ein Produkt, auf das
ich mega mega stolz bin. Das belege ich jetzt mit Backpapier, dann sieht man mein wunderschönes Logo leider nicht mehr, aber ist nicht schlimm!
Einmal mit Backpapier belegen und dann..
So das war jetzt ein bisschen laut, sorry.
Und dann einfach die Teigrohlinge drauflegen mit etwas Abstand und
dann decken..
- Warum Abstand?
Weil sie noch etwas aufgehen werden.
Ach stimmt, die werden ja größer.
- Genau die werden größer und dann decke ich sie ab und lasse sie nochmal 20 Minuten gehen.
Also ich stelle immer solche Fragen weil ich bin so ein Anfänger...
Ja das ist gut ,das ist gut, weil guck mal ich hätte die Frage sonst nicht beantwortet, wenn du nicht gefragt hättest.
Aber jetzt wissen es die Leute ja!
- Ja, echt super!
Und jetzt wie gesagt mit einem Tuch bedecken und in 20 Minuten sehen wir uns
wieder, wenn ihr 30 Minuten Zeit habt, dann lasst es auch gerne 30 Minuten aufgehen. Aber mindestens 20 Minuten solltet ihr schon einhalten. Bis gleich!
So das Ergebnis nach der zweiten Ruhzeit, also sie sind nochmal deutlich aufgegangen
und die Milchbrötchen wären ja keine Milchbrötchen, wenn wir das jetzt nicht noch mit Milch
bestreichen würden. Also vor dem Backen und wir haben hier übrigens garkein Ei im Rezept, das finde ich ganz cool, so Ei-freie Rezepte gehen ja immer.
Man hat ja nicht immer Eier da und ich bestreiche das jetzt und dann backe ich sie.
Wir haben jetzt noch ein bisschen Milch übrig, das benutzen wir gleich. Denn jetzt kommt es erstmal in den Backofen bei
190 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze für ca 25
Minuten und nach dem Backen - ganz, ganz wichtig, das sage ich euch jetzt schon mal - nehmen wir die Milch und bestreichen die Milchbrötchen
heiß nochmal mit Milch und dann können wir sie auskühlen lassen beziehungsweise lauwarm essen. Also bis nachher!
Meine Milchbrötchen sind gerade ganz frisch aus dem Ofen, tut mir einen Gefallen und schaut schon bei 20 Minuten nach, bei mir haben sie heute
23 Minuten gebraucht und jetzt wie gesagt noch ganz heiß mit der Milch bestreichen. Die Milch ist ganz einfach nur
lauwarm bis kalt, also da müsst ihr jetzt nicht besonders viel bei
beachten.
Und danach könnt ihr sie leicht abkühlen lassen, ich mag die gern lauwarm oder auch kalt. Und die bleiben wirklich zwei bis drei Tage lang richtig
schön frisch und fluffig. Wichtig ist halt nur, dass ihr das Ganze
luftdicht verpackt, entweder in der Brotdose oder ihr macht einfach die ganze Zeit über ein Tuch drüber.
Bei mir hält's eh nichtmal ne Stunde...
- Ich weiß! Hamza hat letztens vier oder fünf auf einmal gegessen.
Nein vier, übertreib mal nicht!
- Also vier ist aber auch schon krass!
Vier, ist in Ordnung Kiki!
- Ja,  es ist vollkommen in Ordnung!
Thema beendet!
- Okay! (lacht)
Sie sind noch 190 Grad heiß aber ich zeige euch trotzdem schon mal, wie fluffig sie sind!
Guckt mal! Genau das meine ich, davon habe ich gesprochen! Ihr drückt, ihr drückt und
Ohh, ich muss einmal aufmachen.
Oh Gott, meine Hand verbennt gerade!
Oh mein Gott!
Das ist wie meine Schwester jetzt sagen würde (sie ist im Jugendalter) Fluffigkeit des Todes!
Auf jeden Fall sind das die fluffigsten Milchbrötchen beziehungsweise Schokobrötchen, die ich je gegessen habe und ich weiß
Bäckereien sind auch toll aber keine Bäckerei hat das bisher hinbekommen.
- Also ganz ehrlich, ich hab noch nie
so leckere Schokobrötchen gegessen wie bei dir.
Oder? Oder?! Ich sag doch!
Also wenn meine Mutter das machen würde, würde sie es glaub ich ein bisschen besser machen, aber bei dir ist es am leckersten.
Das ist okay, das ist okay. Auf jeden Fall sind das wirklich die fluffigsten wirklich ever, ever einfach und ihr habt auch gesehen
Zutaten hat man immer da, also
alles habe ich immer da. Auch die Schokodrops und das habt ihr bestimmt auch!
- Bitte macht das nach, das schmeckt hammer!
Macht das nach, wir flehen euch an!
Wir wollen euch ja nichts Böses! Macht's auf jeden Fall nach!
Postet es mit dem Hashtag kikiskitchen auf Instagram, gerne auch auf Facebook und dann freue ich mich natürlich wenn ihr diesem Video ein Däumchen
nach oben gebt, wenn euch das Rezept gefallen hat und hinterlasst auch gerne einen Kommentar. Was habt ihr so in der
Jugend oder in der Kindheit auf dem Pausenhof gerne gegessen? Schreibt's gerne mal rein, das würd' mich auch mal sehr interessieren.
Bestimmt haben die immer diese Frischhaltefolien gehabt da!
Und diese Alufolie!
- Ja klar, logisch!
Also ich hab da immer so ein arabisches Brot gehabt und dann hat meine Mutter es mir immer so mitgegeben. Also mit Alufolie.
Mit Alufolie? Ich hab auch das Gefühl  früher war man sich gar nicht so dessen bewusst, jetzt hat man natürlich Frischhaltedosen der Umwelt zuliebe.
Bestimmt gibt's auch paar Leute, die sagen werden: Meine Mama hat immer den Rand abgeschnitten für mich!
Bestimmt! Schreibt's auf jeden Fall mal rein!
- Das waren dann diese Uncoolen! (lacht)
Hamza! So Pausenhofstories...schreibt's auf jeden Fall mal rein.
und schaut in die Infobox, da stehen alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben drin und ansonsten natürlich -  Moment ich bin gleich wieder da!
Und das Abo nicht vergessen!
Es ist komplett kostenlos! Und die Glocke
aktivieren und dann verpasst ihr auch kein Video mehr von uns! Eine schrieb gestern auf Instagram (weil wir hatten das auf Instagram gezeigt)
"Das hört sich an wie: Aboo! Nicht vergessen!"
So "Aboo!" (lacht)
Naja egal, ich wünsche euch jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag und wir sehen uns im nächsten Rezeptvideo! Tschüüss!
Siehst du das?
- Fluffigkeit des Todes!
Fluffigkeit des Todes! (lacht)